cody it is so wonderful to connect with
you tonight i know the adrenaline rush
is in your body you are
officially big brother all-star winner i
mean has a sunken and the fact you got
nine votes i'm just a little bit
overwhelmed for you
how are you doing i don't even i don't
know it's so
wide it's so wild to me it has it
definitely has not sunk in
um i don't know when it will it's not
right now but i
every time i like check in i'm like oh
my god you just won big brother but like
it's still
like i feel like i'm just saying it to
myself but it hasn't like sunk in you
know
um but i'm just i don't know i'm so i'm
so happy i know i'm happy
i'm so happy oh and you do it
you threw a twist that we did not expect
and we we thought you were gonna take
nicole all the way
you took enzo as the second place yes
you know
okay you have strategy in this game so i
have a feeling you made this decision
a while back that you were going to take
enzo to the end um
i made the decision i wanted to be loyal
to enzo
but the decision really came the
decision came in
this i was confirmed this week because i
was going over all the different
scenarios this week once we were in the
final three because i never really went
too far ahead like that
because then i felt like i would have
overwhelmed myself but this week when we
were in the final three
i was like nicole won the first round i
won the second and so i went through the
different scenarios of
nicole wins takes me how are these votes
going i thought she was going to beat me
like easy i thought she was going to
beat me then i was like i win i take her
i felt like i could beat her but like i
could not like
it could go her way and i was like i
wouldn't i take enzo
i was like i have so many points because
like i i sweep away his
not being nominated because i was not
nominated and took him i wasn't gonna
forget to mention that
like i did with derek and i just felt
like between that my strategy and the
game the competitions i'd won
and just the relationships that i had i
felt like
him and i both had great relationships
but i felt like my relationships were
like those strategic like
make these decisions and i felt like the
people that i was doing that with
would ultimately view my social game
kind of
in a similar rank but more like a little
more powerful and so like
it was very calculated but i still also
i can't say that the personal aspect
wasn't there because i really wanted
enzo to be in the final two
i mean that weighed heavily on me
because i talked about it a lot and i
felt like
he was dogged a lot on his season for
not really winning a lot of comps and
his strategy wasn't implemented
and he is somebody who is he's got a
great personality he's a big personality
but
having those conversations with him he
has a ton of strategy and he understands
about the game and so i don't know that
that was
i feel like i wanted to give him a
chance to like i don't know i i
there was also a personal aspect too and
his kids and all that so
all of that yeah and there you are in
your cardigan you were crying we were
crying with you
that's gonna be a staple cardigan this
could be one of the best sellers
tomorrow i bet you that's what's gonna
happen
it made a statement man is that
the statement cardigan it's a statement
cardigan i'm like yeah
oh i love this card a card i get on
everybody's like i'm like yo i'm leisure
i got ripped jeans and a cardigan on
like whatever y'all me i i love it i
love it and angel's look was amazing too
um uh nicole she was surprised this was
happening what does it mean you guys are
friends you made this deal on day two
uh you guys were together in season 16.
what did it mean for you to be able to
take this game with her
to the end almost oh my god it was
i almost had to like pinch myself at
certain moments because
i was like oh my god like her
her get she is so incredible at this
game
and i i don't she didn't get a chance to
really show it on 16
and i feel like 18 like she definitely
was incredible and then this season like
it would there's just really not a
question about like the player that she
is
yeah what he does and it's like if
there's a naysayer it's just almost like
a hater because she is so incredible at
this game
um and her understanding of the game and
the stuff that she does she's just
incredible and so
to play this game with her and be like
going to the end i was like oh my god
like
i did it with eric now i'm doing it with
her but i felt like with derek
it was like i had relationships where it
was like yo this is what we need to do
with nicole it was like let's
talk like i think this is what we need
to do she was like i don't think that's
what we need to do and i was like well
this is my reasoning and she would be
like
well i don't agree and like this is mine
it was like even though we were like
bigger in a way it would almost be like
a partnership like of like
we would butt heads like kind of like
siblings like and i'd be like well i
think this is it this has got to be the
move for us
and um the crazier thing was like i also
felt like i had that with enzo and so
like to be sitting at the end with the
two of them i was like
what even happened i was like how did i
get here with both of them
like they were the most important aspect
of my game without one of them
i don't have the same game they like i
needed the both of them
and so i just felt like to get to the
final three with them was even more of
an accomplishment i was like
how did us three get how did i sort of
get here with like youtube being my
number ones like they were my number
ones
and so yeah it was it was i mean it's a
surreal experience
are you looking forward to the wedding
when you get out of the house and get
home
to see nicole finally get married oh i
gotta be honest i would always mess with
her all season i'd be like i don't know
if i'm gonna come to the wedding like i
wasn't
i wasn't invited like you were inviting
half of our cast
like well i was like maybe if i win i'll
go so now i
can't get out of it now i have to go now
you have to go in that card again
yeah in the wrong way what's up with the
card again
feeling like the card again is like not
the move
i love it i love it no you don't you no
you know
it's 1am you're in toronto
where's the 2am uh you know one of the
great things about this
you you talk about the strategy you
played almost the perfect game you
played an
all-star game were you influenced by
derrick in season 16 and making sure
that strategy was strong yeah without a
doubt i felt like
the game that i played on 16 was so like
it was just not strategy driven and the
strategy was derek and that's why i
thought him and i had such an incredible
duo because now i saw on the other end
like
what information coming in and
processing it is like and that's what i
felt like
i would find information in big brother
16 bring it back to derek
we would talk about it and then he would
like process it like a computer
and i felt like this season it was very
it was like
i would have my relationships and then
when information would come to me i
would process it in ways that i was just
absolutely not doing on 16.
and a lot of times i was thinking back
and being like how was derek
because i feel like there was a similar
situation on 16 how did derrick process
this because i would remember stuff they
would say to me
and so i would process the information
that i was getting
and like mirroring it to like stuff that
i could relate it to
which was from 16. and so
he did influence my game i can't i can't
say that i would have been
in the position i was in if it wasn't
for derrick so like
would you say you played a better game
than derek um i
i can't say i can't say that i played a
better game i i feel like hit
he's so he was such a different he was a
new
you know like when you mirror somebody
it's almost like you kind of like their
style like
he was such a he was a whole new style
the big brother and that's why he's a
legend i feel like i was somebody that
i think i think i respect the game that
i played and i felt i felt
very confident when i said i'm very
confident that i deserve the money this
time
and i felt very confident with that i
mean i feel like i i gotta i can't say
that i would have done it if it wasn't
for playing the game with him so
i can't like be like oh yeah i'm better
than derek that's just that wouldn't
even be me i
i that doesn't seem like something yeah
yeah you played an excellent game so
so proud of you and congratulations on
that and with the 500
000 you don't know what you're going to
do with it but here's just an
idea you know you potentially get a ring
for your beautiful girlfriend you know
this is a chance to go
shopping you could do that
i know i missed i missed our anniversary
being in here i'm
uh i just been three months away from
her so
i definitely have i make it up somehow
right but yeah that's
what happened and you have a rose right
behind you it's it's all set up for you
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna take it with me
that's perfect this fake road is gonna
like i think
that'll be it i'm like i'm not getting
you anything but i'm going to give you
this rose and this is going to be more
oh congratulations cody i'm so glad we
caught up and uh
it was a great season to see you do this
and i hope we see you again on big
brother oh thank you so much
you